hi this is our first time in Germany and
I'm traveling with my cousin and my best
friend and we're really excited to see
Cologne
we're here because we heard there's a
lot of beautiful places to see and fun
things to do so come with us as we
explore this amazing city pretty amazing
isn't it guys how long do you think it
took to build this place I would
probably say it took a few hundred years
look at how beautiful the Rhine is
these buildings they're amazing the way
they hang out over top it's like they're
not being supported it's just I've never
seen anything like it bridge is
absolutely incredible heard it's one of
the busiest ones in all Europe something
like over a thousand trains every single
day
Wow
I heard you once you lock your lock on
there you throw the key in the river and
as long as the lock stays up your love
is Stace eternal yeah eternal that's
pretty cool yeah pretty cool tradition
they got here
is this legal here it's totally good
this is something totally new we never
really see people climb like this on
bridges and cities that was really
really hard
very cool crossing the river right now
going over the freeway it's exactly what
I thought Germany would look like I
thought every building in Germany would
look like this it's how many beer
gardens do you think there are right in
this area
everything looks so like it comes from
like a movie or something Old Town is
definitely my favorite part of the city
so far
it's like a good spot is the name of
this is coach college I like this class
it's very nice seems like everyone else
has a colsch in a skinny glass as well
must be a tradition I got to get a
picture of this one oh yeah you're gonna
need one you're gonna need a picture
this bad boy today's been a great day
but a lot of fun we've seen a lot of
cool things but it's time for us to
enjoy our meal and enjoy the last bit of
time we have here in Cologne
so goodbye everyone